[Música]
el comandante ucraniano de las fuerzas
terrestres en el este del país llegó a
Bad mood horas después de que el líder
del grupo de mercenarios rusos Wagner
dijera que la ciudad está casi
completamente rodeada y pidiera las
tropas ucranianas que abandonen la urbe
sumida en una de las batallas más largas
de la guerra
el grupo de expertos en derechos humanos
sobre Nicaragua halló que el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega comete graves violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos que suponen
crímenes de lesa humanidad contra la
población civil el comité investigador
recibió el mandato de Naciones Unidas a
raíz de la represión de las protestas de
2018 tenemos análisis en esta edición
la revista Time la más leída de Estados
Unidos cumple 100 años de historia Un
siglo de nuestro tiempo que queda
reflejado en sus icónicas portadas en
esta edición repasaremos los momentos
más destacados de esta publicación
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de la guerra en Ucrania porque a esta
hora avanza la intensa batalla por el
control de batmut una de las batallas
más largas de la guerra que podría
entrar en sus últimas horas este viernes
el comandante del ejército de tierra
ucraniano para el este del país visitó a
las tropas que defienden la ciudad del
asedio ruso la llegada del comandante
ucraniano tuvo lugar pocas horas después
de que el líder del grupo Wagner pidiera
las tropas de kiev que abandonen
backmuth Dado que los rusos tienen la
ciudad prácticamente rodeada
el cerco se hiciera alrededor de bahutts
ese fue el mensaje transmitido por el
fundador del grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner en un vídeo publicado el viernes
se dirigió directamente al presidente
ucraniano
las unidades del grupo Wagner han
rodeado efectivamente backmud Solo queda
un camino las pinzas se están cerrando
anteriormente luchábamos contra el
ejército profesional ucraniano pero hoy
nos enfrentamos cada vez más a los
ancianos y los niños están luchando
contra nosotros pero sus vidas son
cortas uno o dos días denles la
oportunidad de salir de la ciudad la
ciudad está realmente rodeada
[Música]
el vídeo muestra a tres ucranianos
capturados pidiendo que les dejen volver
a casa si mahmud caes sería la primera
Gran Victoria de Moscú en medio año
durante meses Wagner ha encabezado el
asalto a la ciudad y una vez fue el
hogar de alrededor de 70.000 personas
ahora la mayoría de la población se ha
ido algunos han unido a un territorio
que ahora está bajo control ruso aquí en
este Refugio a unas dos horas al sur de
bahamut el líder separatista de
duninas que habían abandonado
recientemente su ciudad esta familia
dice que fueron evacuados por
combatientes de Wagner
estábamos esperando la evacuación porque
no queríamos ir a Ucrania queríamos ir a
Rusia
esperaron y ocurrió esperamos en los
sótanos
el control del ejército ucraniano sobre
la ciudad parece Ahora más tenue que
nunca el viernes temprano por la mañana
el comandante de una unidad ucraniana de
aviones no tripulados en bahmud dijo que
se le había ordenado retirarse de la
ciudad
la guerra de en Ucrania También estuvo
en el centro de la agenda de la Cumbre
del g-20 que se celebró en Nueva Delhi
en India tras la cita de las 20 grandes
potencias del mundo el ministro de
exteriores rusos sergei cargó contra
occidente y aseguró que fue Ucrania
quien empezó la guerra un comentario que
lejos de ser novedoso desató las
carcajadas de los asistentes
[Música]
influence influencers
en otras noticias Naciones Unidas acusa
al ejército de myanmar de crear una
crisis perpetua de vulneraciones de los
Derechos Humanos el organismo pide el
cese de la violencia en que está sumido
el país Desde que la junta militar tomó
el poder mediante un golpe estado en
febrero de 2021 un hecho que desató
protestas pacíficas pero también una
guerra civil entre las fuerzas armadas y
las guerrillas de hecho el informe
señala que la situación es
particularmente violenta en el
noroccidente y en el sureste del país
donde el ejército bombardea de forma
indiscriminada causando masacres y
desplazamiento de población civil con el
objetivo de impedir el acceso de los
actores armados no estatales a distintos
recursos
en otras noticias también en el marco de
la gira del presidente francés por
cuatro países centroafricanos Emanuel
macron y el presidente de Angola Joe
Lorenzo presenciaron la firma de un
acuerdo agroindustrial entre sus
respectivos estados a pesar de que
Angola no fue Colonia francesa sino
portuguesa París ha desarrollado
importantes vínculos económicos con este
país africano el mayor productor de
petróleo del continente donde operan
multinacionales francesas como total
energias
Angola una potencia del Oro negro la
antigua Colonia portuguesa produce un
millón 200.000 barriles de petróleo al
día el recurso representa el 40% de su
producto interior bruto mientras que los
hidrocarburos suponen el 90% de sus
exportaciones una operación que lleva a
cabo la petrolera local pero también las
grandes occidentales como total Energy
presente en el país desde 1953 la
empresa francesa emplea allí unas 1.100
personas y construye plataformas
petroleras pero también infraestructura
de producción de energía renovable ahora
Emmanuel macron está de viaje en Angola
el jefe de estado francés quiere poner
su visita bajo el signo de la
diversificación económica Francia
pretende ayudar a Angola a conquistar su
soberanía alimentaria luanda depende de
sus importaciones de alimentos básicos a
pesar de los importantes recursos
hídricos y un clima favorable para la
agricultura el país explota solo 5,9
millones de hectáreas de su tierra
cultivable cuando son 35 millones los
que tiene disponibles Angola espera
atraer inversores franceses para
explotar este potencial una ardua tarea
para un país no francófono con un clima
de negocios difícil
el objetivo declarado del mandatario
francés en este viaje es re dibujar las
relaciones entre Francia y el continente
africano en sus propias palabras
hacerlas Más igualitarias sin embargo
también dijo que quiere favorecer la
influencia de la Unión Europea en el
Continente una región donde recordemos
China y Rusia ganan cada vez más terreno
en República democrática del Congo la
siguiente parada de la gira de macrón
muchos ciudadanos rechazan
definitivamente la influencia francesa
escuchemos
ahora quiere seducirnos quiere volver a
colonizar el Congo porque entiende que
gran parte de África occidental le está
dando la espalda a Francia
ahora quiere venir a África Central a
seducir y buscar una sociedad y seguir
colonizando
en África decimos que no
siento que si el enemigo invisible se
hace visible es una buena oportunidad
para hablar con el cara a cara sobre lo
que está pasando en el este del Congo
vamos con información de nuestra región
el gobierno de Nicaragua está cometiendo
violaciones generalizadas de Derechos
Humanos que constituyen crímenes de lesa
humanidad contra civiles motivados por
razones políticas esto asegura el
informe realizado por el grupo de
expertos en derechos humanos sobre
Nicaragua un organismo independiente
mandatado por el consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU según el documento
desde las manifestaciones que buscaban
reformas sociales en el año 2018 se han
cometido y se siguen cometiendo graves
violaciones y abusos a los derechos
humanos en la nación centroamericana
desde ginebra para el análisis
conectamos ahora con Ángela buitreago
del grupo redactor del informe Ángela
buenas tardes para usted para nuestra
audiencia le pido que si puede ser si
puede ser empecemos por una breve
síntesis de los principales hallazgos de
su investigación
gracias buena tarde también para usted
queríamos precisar dos aspectos
fundamentales para hacer una resumen de
lo que se halló por parte del grupo y en
el informe sobre actos que generan una
planeación para un ataque frente a esa
persecución que hemos encontrado y esto
significa también hablar de que esto se
vino realizando a través de reformas
constitucionales legales y de una u otra
manera frente a procesos en donde se
ejecutaron de manera coordinada con
diferentes estructuras del Estado
acciones que fueron sistemáticas y
generalizadas dentro de un ataque que
implica violaciones y crímenes de toda
índole encontramos prueba de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales de tortura de
detenciones arbitrarias de
cierres de espacios cívicos electorales
y sociales que llevan sin lugar a dudas
a concluir al grupo de manera razonable
que hay toda una planeación para ese
ataque con fines de persecución frente a
opositores políticos e inclusive a
personas que se perciben como posibles
opositores este tema culmina con el
periodo de febrero de este año cuando se
genera la expulsión el destierro y la
pérdida de nacionalidad
de varios nicaragüenses
y precisamente Ángela respecto a esta
expulsión cómo debería leerse porque
Estados Unidos por ejemplo la celebró
como una Liberación
creo que de todos modos Hay que entender
que en el momento en que se concede la
posibilidad de que salgan de la
detención ilícita o de la prisión se
genera un doble movimiento por parte del
gobierno nicaragüense que inclusive
tampoco conocían las personas que fueron
llevadas a un avión y es que mientras
ellos estaban firmando un documento en
donde manifestaban la voluntad de irse a
otro país a la par la asamblea estaba
realizando una modificación para generar
la pérdida de la nacionalidad de estas
personas son actos que son casi
inmediatos Ángela muy rápidamente porque
Lamentablemente se nos acaba el tiempo
ustedes piden a la comunidad
internacional que imponga sanciones sin
embargo el gobierno de Ortega y Murillo
está bastante aislado y el aislamiento
no puede propiciar mayores a violaciones
de derechos humanos ante una impunidad
Sí claro y precisamente las sanciones
deben tomarse de manera inmediata
precisamente para generar el principio
de protección en favor de la población
nicaragüense estas acciones son
permitidas por el derecho internacional
y creemos que los países y esa es la
recomendación que hace el Green deben
analizar la posibilidad de imponer estas
sanciones de manera efectiva para lograr
proteger a la población de nicaragüense
Ángela buitrago entonces un placer a
conversar con usted Muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros en France 24
igual y muchas gracias felicitar
nosotros cambiamos de información porque
como avanzábamos en los titulares se
cumple hoy El centenario de la revista
Time el medio de información más leído
en Estados Unidos cumple un siglo con
más de un millón de suscriptores y más
de 5000 números a sus espaldas para
analizar esta efeméride nos acompaña
Marta Moya en el estudio Marta Maya
Buenos días buenas tardes Rosa empezamos
haciendo un poco de memoria de este
Centenario no es así sí vamos a hacer un
poco de memoria porque tal día como hoy
3 de marzo de 1923 se publicaba el
primer número de la revista Time y para
celebrar este hito pues la revista ha
sacado una portada con 144 de sus
portadas más emblemáticas a lo largo de
este primer siglo de vida también han
desarrollado un proyecto web esta semana
llamado Un siglo de impacto que repasa
un poco la historia de la revista de la
mano de sus portadas sus artífices y de
las entrevistas que se han llevado a
cabo a lo largo de estos Cien años los
directivos comentan que estos Cien años
este Centenario significa un marcador de
constancia y cambio vemos ahora en la
primera portada de la revista Time al
legislador republicano conocido como el
tío Joe que entonces anunciaba su retiro
como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes estadounidenses vemos en
esa primera portada trazos hechos a
manos sin color con el protagonista de
la historia en el centro que es bueno
una premisa que han venido utilizando a
lo largo de todos estos años y Marta
hemos querido destacar algunas portadas
en particular Sí vamos a destacar las
cinco portadas más emblemáticas y esto
es un gran trabajo de síntesis porque de
5000 números a cinco van muchos
imaginero empezamos en 1966 con una
portada emblemática que se pregunta está
muerto Dios hemos destacado una segunda
de mayo de 2012 que fue muy que se
preguntaba eres lo suficientemente madre
la tercera portada que hemos destacado
es de la caída de las Torres Gemelas en
el año 2001 la cuarta es un retrato esta
fue muy famosa un retrato de Aisha que
es una mujer afgana que fue sentenciada
por los talibanes a que le cortaran la
nariz y las orejas y la quinta portada
que hemos destacado es de 2016 y es de
Donald Trump con esa niña migrante que
le llora con el titular Bienvenidos a
Estados Unidos y Marta sin duda las
portadas icónicas también son aquellas
que destacan la persona del año no que
anualmente precisamente elige el consejo
editorial de esta revista Así es desde
1927 se viene desarrollando esta
práctica No una vez al año normalmente
al final hemos destacado la de este 2022
que no podía ser otro que bolodimir
zelensky Pero esto es un tema también un
poco controvertido porque no siempre
otorgar el título o la premiación el
reconocimiento personal del año implica
que tenga una connotación positiva no ha
estado Putin ha estado en ayatola
jamenei y bueno no siempre es tan
positivo como aparece como aparenta
Perdón Así es Marta bueno se nos acaba
el tiempo pero muchísimas gracias por
este repaso por las portadas más
icónicas de la revista Time a ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
enseguida volvemos
[Música]